foreign
let's go to Lynn in Boston hey Lynn
what's up
thanks Dr John thanks for taking my call
hi thank you so much for calling what's
happening
um
I gotta tell you after that story these
pretzels are making me feel really
thirsty
those are Mickey
so so my situation so I have a 19 year
old daughter she met a really nice young
man last summer uh great qualities great
family values just overall really nice
young man
um he enlisted in the military at the
end of last summer so the relationship
was short to begin with
um they continued their relationship we
attended his military graduation with
his family
he came home at Christmas time asked her
to marry him so they're currently
engaged okay
um a couple weeks ago uh she started
hanging out with a
them from work
cheating on her fiancee oh
um yeah so I confronted her we had a
long talk I let her know that I didn't
agree with what she was doing and I
couldn't support it
I told her that I understand that she's
in a very difficult situation and I
don't agree with her choices but I did
offer to walk alongside her if she were
to do the right thing
so you know I suggested that she paused
the relationship with the new person and
speak with her fiance and let him know
exactly what was going on
and I also suggested that potentially
because it was such a sticky and hairy
situation that she get a counselor to
walk alongside her with with her and
agreed you know I offered to pay for it
and she scheduled an appointment with a
pet with a counselor
um stated that what she was doing was
wrong and that she wanted to speak to
her fiance about everything
um but I found out last week that she
didn't stop cheating didn't pause
anything hasn't spoken with her fiance
and to make things worse
um she's planning on going to see him
with his family at the end of this week
oh wow
does she live with you
she does yes
who does she work
she does she's she works full-time
um during the summer and then goes to
college and works part-time when she's
in college
ma'am
I'm going so before I just start
answering questions I want to make sure
I don't answer questions you're not
asking
um okay
because I have a visceral response
across the board on this as I know you
do too
um so how can I help let me start there
well I guess I just have this guilt that
I owe him the truth or his family the
truth
you know and I'm trying to get her to do
the right thing and come clean with him
and you know
um I think she's having a hard time with
it because she wants to be with him and
I think ultimately he would be her
choice
but in order to be with him she has to
marry him now move with him choose the
military life for the next three years
and being 19 I honestly don't know if
she's ready to make that obviously we
know she's not ready to make that choice
but I just think that yeah she doesn't
want to be with him she wants to be with
the idea of him
because being with him is is comes with
all those things you just mentioned
right right my wife wants to be with me
and I'm a lunatic right I'm a lot and we
live out in the woods and also I work in
media and so we get stopped at every
dinner we have now I so but she wants to
be with all of me not an idea a
romanticized picture of what you might
part of you does that make sense yeah
absolutely and so yeah she doesn't want
to be with him not by a long shot she
wants to be with this idea of him
um and that's a huge difference
um
so
I'm gonna probably end up giving you a
recommendation that I don't normally
recommend
um
first and foremost
you seem to like this guy more than she
does
and that's pretty common and it would be
cool
um I think you're gonna have to keep
that to yourself
okay okay um you like this guy and you
it's I can just by your description of
him you if if we fast forwarded four or
five years you'd you would love for your
daughter to have ended up with this guy
right totally so there's that
um before I before I start
running my mouth here
did she learn this at home anywhere or
is there any sort of deceptive we kind
of just keep things quiet just put your
head down she pick that up anywhere I
would say communication hasn't always
been key
um so maybe
essentially yeah tell me a little bit
more you said that very in a very uh
flat flower communication hasn't always
been key I mean that's you know I've had
relationships where it's like like I'm
in a relationship where I could totally
communicate better you know so
with the cheating like I know there's
been no never been deception as far as
that like I've been cheated on in my
life I was with someone that had a
fiance I didn't know about it did you
did you tell her that yes okay you know
I've explained to her that I've been on
the other end and it sucks yeah yeah
okay you know so
here's the thing
um when it comes to addiction I often
Buck the system and if it's safe
I always want people to have a place to
come home
and the conventional wisdom in some
circles is you kick their butt out of
there when they get their life back then
they can move out and I know that
addiction is a connection issue right
um now someone's not being saved for
whatever then they have to go stay
somewhere else
but in this situation it's different
because they are actively
hurting somebody
other than themselves and I know
addiction hurts everybody I know all
that but
what I would tell her I'm just thinking
if this is my child
you are not welcome to use my home base
as something as a platform for you to
actively hurt somebody
in the way that you are
and
the important thing here is is that she
is making this choice not you
right so you are not kicking her out as
much as
she is choosing to leave
and I think it would be really important
for you to sit down and say hey one of
the cornerstones I've thought about this
more number one I haven't been great at
communicating things and I'm going to
start working on that getting better
like when I have to have a hard
conversation I'm gonna I'm gonna start
taking proactive steps to get better at
that and I didn't model that for you
will and I'm sorry
but the more I've thought about what's
happening here and remembering being on
the other end of this
um one of my core values is to always
tell the truth and to never cheat or
deceive somebody even when it's hard and
I can't allow I I am choosing to not
allow that to happen here I want you to
live with me I want you to be here but
if you're going to continue to actively
enter into the destruction of somebody
else's life
long long tail destruction on this deal
then you're choosing to go live
somewhere else and I hope you'll make a
different choice
does that make sense yeah totally we've
had I mean we've kind of been leading
them lead work if you don't then I will
be forced to have that conversation
either with him or his parents and I I
don't think that's the right move for
you I think that would be such a
violation of her trust over time
um I don't know that that's the right
move I think that she needs to Bear the
weight of this as she's an adult making
adult decisions
um and I really think it's important
that she understands she is choosing
this
not there's she there hasn't been a line
in the sand whereby mom has to uh is
weaponizing our relationship that's not
what's happening here Mom has a set of
values that I'm choosing to not live
into
so I'm choosing to leave
and that sounds subtle but that's a huge
difference because then every phone call
you have
when she's moving is I hope you'll stay
here I really hope you'll stay here
um how do you think this ends I hope
you'll choose to stay here and not
choose to leave
but this is one of the values that is is
you have to have to live in my house
right and I would say this is hard but
she's welcome to break up with her
fiance and I hope you'll still love her
if she breaks up with us and I don't
care what you choose you know but that's
that's your choice I just want you to do
the right thing yeah be a person of
Integrity make a choice yeah make a
choice and it doesn't even have to be
either or it can be you you can you can
make choose you yeah and you know put
the time and effort into you and
figuring out what you want you know that
what's going to benefit you in the long
run but just remember 19 year olds are
still they're not listening as much as
they're watching
and that's where
you're walking through a very clear hard
conversation is going to provide a model
for her to have a very clear and hard
conversation
using words like you know kinda we've
been thinking or communication is kind
of key it's got to be very very clear
I spent some time this last week writing
down my values and I should have done
this a long time ago and I didn't
one of them is we tell the truth and we
are people of integrity and right now
you're not being a person of integrity
you're you're willingly intentionally
trying to hurt somebody
and I think that's what bothers me the
most it is and it should right it should
yeah this would be if this dude wasn't
as he's a great guy and that makes this
example easier even if he was an idiot
he was a scumbag he still don't you
still don't do that you know what I mean
absolutely you still put that out there
so
um I would spend some time with my
values and I would spend some time being
honest with her about I haven't been
good at communication and that's going
to change and so here's where we are um
here's our values and maybe she'll join
you she probably won't but maybe she'll
join you in a values exercise and say
who are we going to be
who re who here's who I'm gonna be I
want to know who you are planning on
being because right now every minute
every hour every day the actions you
take or don't take is contributing to
the person you're going to become and
let's be intentional about that let's
just don't wake up somewhere on an
island and be like how do we get here
now let's be intention about who we're
going to become
and one of those core core values and
virtues is I'm going to be a person of
integrity
and then you have to have a hard
conversation about here's a boundary of
mine and I hope hope you'll choose I'll
hold your hand while you make the call
um I'll fly with you out there if you
want to do it in person whatever that
looks like
um
but yeah and for God Almighty don't go
on a trip with his parents that's just
oh geez that's just gross man that's
gross hey thank you for loving her and
sometimes love comes with hard moments
of boundaries and accountability and
it's hard it's hard
um
she's lucky to have you